welcome back y'all we are here with the
cast of the Super Mario Brothers movie
which is in theaters everywhere in April
we've got Chris Pratt Charlie Day king
of knuckle King Jack Black
so you you've all been here before
except for Bowser except for Jack it's
my first team
we've partied before we did a charity
thing together and uh and the first time
you don't even remember we I said I sat
right I sat next to the it was I think I
was still an idol but it was whenever it
was whenever Michael Jackson accepted
the award that wasn't an award oh yeah
and it was like happy birthday and he
was like and he said thank you for being
the artist of the Millennium and
everyone was like hmm oh yeah it was a
crazy moment yeah that was it that one
too anyway I remember that I remember
sitting next to you because I love you
so oh anyway yeah I just said you got
pipes for days we should do a duet one
of these days
today you would have killed it it was
like let's do this shredded um so
basically because my voice is shot but I
actually love y'all are all musical
everyone sitting here is musical so what
I mean Tenacious D obviously yeah
like did you was that your first love
when you were a kid did you think you
would
um no I was a real ham and it didn't
matter if it was singing or acting
whatever I just like to get up in front
of a crowd and I was doing both from an
early age I was singing and acting yeah
yeah putting on a show didn't really
matter old school Showman foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody